If you're building an agentic system
today or going to be building it
tomorrow, I want to introduce you to the
concept of prompt tax. My talk's broken
down into four sections. The pain of
progress, what it's like to ship at the
frontier, a bunch of advice in the form
of battle tested tactics, and then
ultimately a series of questions about
how to think about paying back the
prompt tax. Let's begin with the first
section, the pain of progress. Here's a
nice animation for Peter Gostov of
Moonpeg that shows you the ELO scores
over time as AI labs are shipping new
models. But what does it actually feel
like to develop with this rate of
progress? Well, for me, it feels like
having a birthday just about every
month. Enthropic recently released
things just in the last couple of weeks.
Google Gemini had a plethora of new
additions to their models and
functionality and OpenAI keep shipping
at a breathtaking pace. But with all
these advances, as you bake a lot of
those functionality into your own
applications, there's a hidden prompt
tax. So, what is that actually like?
It's like getting a new bike on your
birthday. You think about riding fast,
uh the new found freedom you may get to
go into your friend's house, but
ultimately some unexpected things can
happen. You go for a ride, you don't
know how to ride a bike, and you fall
over and you hurt yourself. Applied to
AI models, there's an incredible amount
of new functionality that you can bolt
into your own applications. But there
are also unintended consequences by
using this probabilistic system that can
behave in ways that are
unexpected. Ultimately, shipping product
at the frontier has this constant
tension between the opportunities that
new AI models can give versus the risks
that you could introduce either
regressions or unintended consequences
to your
products. Let's look at what shipping at
the frontier of AI is really like. I'm
the CTO of a company called Orbital with
offices both in New York and London. The
mission of our business is to automate
real estate due diligence so that we can
fast forward the transaction of
properties. Why does this matter? We all
live in homes. We all work in offices
and every time those get developed and
bought and sold, real estate lawyers are
involved in the due diligence of those
properties which often involve reading
mountains of paperwork um hunting for
needles and a hay stack in order to find
red flags for their clients before those
properties can be transacted. Our
Agentic software helps to supercharge
that process by radically reducing the
time to find those needles in a hay
stack and compile all the needed
paperwork in order to complete a real
estate
transaction. This is our team. It's
neither New York or London, but it's
sunny Morca. We were at an offsite.
We're roughly 80 people. Half of that is
the product engineering team. And in
terms of how we're structured, we have a
product manager and designer that head
up the team. We then have domain experts
that are embedded in that team. We then
have software engineers and AI engineers
and a tech lead that oversees uh the
delivery of how all of this sort of
cross functional team works together to
ship working agentic
products. Let's rewind way back to
January 2024. We had just developed our
first agentic product called orbital
co-pilot. It thought like a real estate
lawyer and we started selling that to
lawyers inside law firms and to real
estate professionals in various
businesses that needed access to to the
work that orbital copilot can
perform. I'm going to show you a quick
demo of the product. It's on sort of
warp speed, so it'll go pretty fast and
I'll uh talk through it pretty quickly,
but I thought it might be helpful to see
what a sort of long running task usually
performed manually by lawyers, reading
paperwork and compiling all of the
information that is extracted manually.
Whereas now we have an agent tool that
does that automatically. Here we go. So
we start by first clicking on a report.
We choose the appropriate occupational
lease report. It then is going to ask us
to upload some documents. In this case,
I've uploaded both a deed and a lease.
One I think has about 30 pages. The
other has about 70 pages, so about 100
pages in turn. It first starts to OCR
all these documents because they have
handwritten and type text. So they need
to be OCR and structured before they can
actually start with the real heavy
lifting. And here it goes. So on the
left hand side there you can see the
agentic system has sort of created a
plan broken that plan down into many
subtasks. Each one of those subtasks or
its own agentic system with multiple LLM
calls. It's been given an objective to
find the date of the lease or the
current annual rent and it's reading all
of these legal documents that you see on
the right uh to find the appropriate
answers. And as you can see each of them
going green here. uh we'll wait until
the last one completes and then a final
report can then be manually reviewed
much more quickly by a lawyer because
all of the necessary information has
been extracted. As you can see here, the
citations can be clicked on very easily
so that a licensed real estate lawyer
can kind of go back to the ground
truth. And then the final step was
downloading the word report uh to get
stored in the system and ultimately sent
to a client in order to progress the
transaction. Okay, so that agentic
system, how is it actually performed
over time? Well, let's rewind back to
when that blog post was written. We
commercialized our agentic agent 18
months ago. We're basically only burning
less than a billion tokens. We're now
within touching distance 18 months later
almost consuming 20 billion tokens every
month on the behalf of uh real estate
lawyers who are working on the behalf of
their clients to process these real
estate transactions. So 20 billion
tokens worth of work that was usually
done manually by lawyers is now done
automatically by our Agentics product.
We've also gone from 18 months ago doing
exactly zero in revenue. We've scaled
that aggressively too to now doing sort
of multiple seven figures in revenue um
of annual recurring revenue over time
and that continues to scale and we're
immensely proud of that.
So where have we got to or where do we
start and where have we got to? We
started on
GPT3.5. We had all these system one
models that we went through. One of my
personal all-time favorites was GPD4
32K. um radically expensive but it
enabled for the first time in a Gentic
system because of that increased context
window. We then migrated to 4 Turbo 40.
We're now using 41 4.1 and we also went
to the system 2 models going from 01
preview when it first came out all the
way to the latest sort of 04 mini and
everything in between. We've had to make
some decisions along the way for better
or worse. And I want to articulate three
of them. The one was to optimize for
prompting over fine tuning. The reason
for that is we wanted to maximize the
speed of development. We got feedback
from users. We adjusted a prompt and
those prompts were pulled in real time
into the Aentic system and so changes
could much more easily get incorporated
into the product, especially in the
early days when we were finding product
market fit. And now once we've had it,
we can continue to ship features at a
blistering pace uh by just simply
adjusting prompts over time. The second
was this heavy reliance on domain
experts. These are private practice real
estate lawyers who worked in law firms
who've come to work for orbital. They
have decades worth of experience and
they are effectively writing many of the
prompts that take the experience that
they've learned over many decades and
essentially teach an AI system about
that expertise. So it has it itself. And
the third um and probably most
controversial one given how eval systems
are all the rage is we've elected to go
for vibes over evals. Um we very much
would like an eval system. It's always
sort of just within touching re distance
on the road map. But it's pretty
incredible seeing the growth we've had
both in terms of tokens, both in terms
of revenue, both in terms of user
feedback that we've come all this way in
18 months on pretty much vibes alone.
And by vibes, I mean not a rigorous
evaluation system that's uh objective,
but more human beings, usually the
domain experts, uh testing out a system
prior to its release. sometimes just
getting a more subjective feel,
sometimes logging things down in
spreadsheets and figuring out if things
have regressed uh from um prior uh model
changes, but nothing that's terribly
comprehensive and much more open to
subjectivity. So, our prompts can be
broken down into two areas. The one
agentic prompts these are pretty much
owned by AI engineers. These are system
prompts. They're in prompts that um deal
with helping the model choose what tools
to use and when and then more domain
specific prompts used by real estate
lawyers um that teach the system uh its
expertise in the real estate domain. So
this is the number of domain specific
prompts over time. Uh we've gone from
near zero in the early days to well over
1,000 prompts. Uh now the challenge with
this is that more prompts equals more
prompt tax and I'll dig into why this
matters fairly shortly. So when a new AI
model drops what we do we experiment
with it rigorously in the week whether
that's the AI engineers or the domain
experts ultimately what we're
experimenting for is we often have
features that we've envisioned. We want
to unlock those features with new
capabilities and we want to see whether
the models are now fit for purpose or we
could get inspired with new ideas um
based on our
experimentation. We then also need to
figure out how much prompt tax is
actually required to migrate the prompts
we have to this new model as well as
there's this inherent fear that exists.
We don't know exactly what will happen
if we ship this new AI model. um there's
a lot of unknown unknowns and so that
inherently creates a bunch of fear and
it's our job to sort of pinpoint where
that's coming from. Is it rational? Can
we mitigate it? If not, let's
ship. I want to stress that prop tax, at
least for me, is not technical debt. If
I think about technical debt, often
you're optimizing for shipping quickly
um and you may fix later. by that um the
feature that you ship may never end up
finding product market fit and you may
just delete it or that little prototype
that you thought was just going to stay
a prototype becomes the core part of the
product and needs to be fundamentally
rebuilt as you scale prompts. However,
there's this desire to upgrade now new
models often unlock new capability and
baking them into your agentic product is
immensely valuable. The problem is of
because of these unknowns, you don't
know exactly what it's going to improve
and what it's going to break. And so
it's this idea of can we fix things on
the fly? Is there an optimal way to
release this new model to sets of users?
Figure out from them, get their feedback
on what's working well and what's not.
Fix that as quickly as you can. Um, and
then roll it out to as many people as
possible. That way you maximize the
benefits of the new AI model while
mitigating hopefully as many of the
downside risks of the model uh
regressing any prior functionality that
users have relied
on. Okay, third section. Let's spend
some time on some of the advice that is
in the form of battle tested tactics
that my team and I have discovered over
the last 18
months when we've migrated from system
one models like GPD40 to system 2 models
like 01 preview. There's sort of um
three things we've come across. This
idea that in system one models we often
had to be very specific about how to
accomplish a tasks. With system two
models, we didn't need to do that. We
needed to strip all that out and just
specify what to do. Related the second
point of making them leaner, but
specifically system one models, you
often needed to repeat a lot of the
instructions to make sure it followed
those instructions as closely as
possible. With system two models, those
could also be removed. And then the
other idea is just fundamentally
unblocking the model. System two models
don't like to be given too many
constraints. They like to be given a
clear objective and then given time to
sort of think through all of the
permutations and rationalize and reason
about the context you've given them in
order to find the appropriate plan and
ultimate end result to feed back to
you. We often, you know, we love system
two models, but system one models can be
really helpful. They're often cheaper.
They're often faster. But one extra
piece is that they often have thought
tokens that either we embed those
thought tokens to users because
especially in our domain, real estate
lawyers would like the added
explanability of understanding sometimes
how the model has thought about a
complex legal matter. Or second, we use
them for debugging that when something
isn't working based on our own uh
experimentation or based on feedback
from users, we can then dig into those
thought tokens and see what might have
gone
wrong. The other piece is software
developers have been really aware of
feature flags over time to sort of
progressively roll out new functionality
to mitigate risk. uh the same concept
can be applied to rolling out new
upgrades to AI models. But I think
there's the change aver bias, the change
aversion bias, this idea that um there
is
inherently more anxiety to the system
you're moving to than the system you
were at. Just because the system you
were at, people knew it. Even if it had
substantial downsides, you were aware of
those. by when you move to a new system,
it could have the same downsides, it
could have other ones, but there's a net
an a natural anxiety that's heightened
by moving to one of these new models.
And so this idea of sort of poking the
bear, um you may end up being fine if
nobody knew that you were moving to a
new model, but simply by articulating
that there is a new model that you're
moving to, everybody's on a heightened
state of awareness to try to look out
for issues. And those issues can
sometimes outweigh the positives of
moving to the new
model. We created a team mantra about
betting on the model. A lot of people
have talked about this. Do not build SAS
software today for features that will
only exist today. Try to imagine where
AI models are going to be 3, 6, 12
months from now and bet that they're
going to get smarter, cheaper, faster,
and have more capabilities. If you bet
right, you can build features that as AI
models become more capable, they make
your product better and you're not
stagnating by building stuff today, but
you're growing with those models over
time. And so by creating this m mantra
we were able to talk about it in terms
of meetings to just sort of shortcircuit
some of the thinking to be like hold on
are we actually thinking correctly about
this product feature and can we think
about it a bit differently if we think
into the future as opposed to the
now. The other hack we have is using
system to models to help us migrate
prompts. A lot of the prompts have been
created for a world with prior models,
but when the latest model comes out, it
knows itself. It's often better than
prior models. And by feeding that domain
specific prompt into the new model, it
can help us migrate those uh prompts and
radically uh decrease the amount of
manual human effort
required. We also need to make some
pretty tough calls. Life is uncertain.
you don't know what exactly is going to
happen with this probabilistic model
with new capabilities. Uh your users are
going to feed it the same things they've
always uh fed your system. They're going
to feed it new use cases and new
prompts. And so ultimately there's a lot
of uncertainty embedded in moving from
model to model. Ultimately, we found
that you need a person, a team that is
able to take on that risk that there
will be positives and negatives of
moving to the new model, but you need to
make that call. You need to ship and
then deal with the consequences after
shipping. Obviously, mitigate a number
of the risks along the way. But there's
this inherent anxiety, as I mentioned
before, that you need to get over. And
sometimes that just takes a little
bravery to say, "Let's ship. It's going
to be all right. Let's
go. It also really helps to make sure
that you have a strong feedback loop.
Whether this is manually given to you
from your users, whether you can bake
this into the product's UX via a simple
sort of thumbs up, thumbs down feedback,
get that feedback in the hands of your
AI engineers and your domain experts as
soon as possible. We've built a system
today. That feedback comes to us through
the product. It immediately gets sent to
a demon expert and that domain expert
evaluates it, figures out what prompt
needs to get changed, makes that change
and then ships that into production to
not only fix that for that user who gave
us the feedback, but also fix it for any
other user who is on the system. And we
can do that sometimes in minutes or
hours as opposed to the days or weeks
long cycles that are sometimes more
traditional uh with bugs coming in.
Deis Havaris, the chief exec of Google
DeepMind, uh, put his finger on
something that I think is really
important in the hard fork podcast the
other day, and I'll I'll let him talk
through it in his own words
here. One of the challenges I think of
this space is obviously the underlying
tech is moving unbelievably fast and I
think that's quite different even from
the other big revolutionary techs,
internet and mobile. at some point you
get some sort of stabilization of the
tech stack so that then the you know the
focus can be on product right or or
exploiting that tech stack and what
we've got here which I think is very
unusual but also quite exciting from a
researcher perspective is that the the
tech stack itself is evolving incredibly
fast as you guys know so I think that
makes it uniquely challenging actually
on the product side um not just for us
at Google and deep mind but for startups
for for anyone really any any any uh
company small and large is where do you
what do you bet on right now when that
could be 100% better uh in a year as
we've seen and and so you've got you've
got this interesting thing where you
need kind of fairly um deeply technical
sort of product people product designers
and managers I think to in order to sort
of intercept where the technology may be
in a year. So there's things it can't do
today and you want to design a product
that's going to come out in a year. So
you've got a kind of you got a pretty
deep understanding of the tech and where
it might go to to sort of work out what
features you can rely on. And so it's
it's it's an interesting one. I think
that's what you're seeing so many
different things being tried out and
then if something works, we got to
really double down quick.
I think there's a real opportunity here
for the AI engineering community. We
used to talk about this with software
engineers that they were sort of product
engineers and then engineers. And if you
could be a product engineer who sort of
understood the customer problem, it was
incredibly powerful to sort of connect
those dots, both the technical and the
user need. And I think AI engineers who
are more sort of product AI engineers,
the sort of bottoms up understanding
what capabilities these models have and
turning them into uh product features
that solve very real user problems. that
connective tissue, the least amount of
people, if it's embedded within one
single AI engineer or a team of them. I
find that to be an incredibly promising
proposition for the future of the AI
engineering
community. Last section, let's talk
about paying the prompt tax. Or
actually, given that this tension
exists, maybe we should just ship now.
Let me dig into it with a series of
questions. Ultimately the meta question
I have is what gives us more confidence
to ship at the frontier of this
AI as AI is moving faster and faster
more functionality is coming out
everybody's a gentic product surface
area is getting bigger and bigger having
more confidence over time is going to
enable us to continue to
innovate we've built our product for the
last 18 months mostly on vibes but I'm
well aware of this idea of will vibes
ultimately scale as the product surface
area increases. At the moment it's doing
well between a combination of domain
experts and user feedback that comes in
real time and that we have tooling to
act on it very quickly. That's scaling
incredibly well. But at some point I can
imagine that becomes harder or breaks
down. And so the question is is an eval
system the answer to that? Maybe. Maybe
it alleviates that, maybe it bends the
curve down and allows us to sort of push
even further. But given all the edge
cases, given the randomness or the sort
of underlying probabilistic nature of
these LLMs, um,
and in our case in real estate legal, we
have not only the correctness of the
answer, we have the style of that
answer, we have the conciseness, and we
have all of the correctness of all of
the citations. It is quite a complex
number of things to embed in an eval
system for all of the different prompts
and use cases that real estate lawyers
throw at our system. And I can imagine
your own agentic systems if you had to
evaluate all of the different edge cases
opposed to just the happy parts. It
becomes prohibitively expensive,
prohibitively slow and it might even be
a bit of an impossible task to create
that many evals as your product velocity
is growing over time.
the progressive delivery. Maybe that's
the way forward. Back to the prompt tax
idea. Uh upgrade now and fix on the fly.
Maybe fixing on the fly can be done by
rolling this out internally first, then
to a limited number of sort of
progressive users and scaling that up to
50 or 100% of users over time. Maybe
it's calibrated based on the amount of
feedback that comes in. You just
incrementally turn it on for more and
more users up until your own internal
teams get swamped with too much feedback
and then you dial it back and you play
that game all the way until you get to
100% and feedback is fairly minimal that
needs to end up changing the product
over
time. There's probably a myriad of other
tactics I either haven't covered here or
that you've experienced yourself. I
guess this is a a call out to the AI
engineering community of just what other
battle tested tactics are there? Which
ones can we add here? Feel free to reach
out to me and let me know um and maybe
we can collaborate together with them on
a future presentation and share them
with the wider community.
So for me, the central thesis of this
presentation, this idea of buy now, if
you want to stay on the edge of the AI
frontier, if you want to maximize the
opportunity from all of the capabilities
that these new models enable, you need
to ship, you need to get that in the
hands of your Aentic product. You need
to get that in the hands of users. Um,
and that anxiety may not be real. you
may not have to pay for any of uh the
downside risk that doesn't occur. Or
maybe you do. Maybe that progressive uh
tactic of sort of incrementally rolling
it out, fixing some feedback for one or
two users before it rolls out to
hundreds or thousands or tens of
thousands is the way forward. But very
much for me, my emphasis, I want to stay
on the frontier. It means I need to buy
now and whether I pay for it not later
is still to be determined on a case-by
case
basis. So that's the end of my
presentation. Big thank you to my team.
Many of the these ideas come straight
for them. So thank you very much. And
finally, I'm Andrew Thompson, CTO of
Orbital. Feel free to email me or reach
out to me on LinkedIn. Um, I'd love any
feedback about this talk, good or bad.
Um, and continue the discussion. And
maybe, just maybe, once we've built our
eval system, we roll that out, I will
have a another presentation all about
the trials and tribulations of that
process and whether it's solved a number
of the things I've raised here